.
>> Bret: SEE YOU LATER.
♪
>> Jesse: HERE AT "PRIMETIME,"
OUR JOB IS TO HOLD POWERFUL
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE.
WHEN THE REST OF THE MEDIA
IGNORES THE BAD BEHAVIOR OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, THE
PELOSIS OR THE CLINTONS AND
EVERYBODY IN BETWEEN, WE STEP
IN.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO GIVE CREDIT
WHERE CREDIT'S DUE.
BIDEN WAS IN ARIZONA TODAY
CELEBRATING A NEW COMPUTER CHIP
FACTORY HERE IN AMERICA.
>> CONSTRUCT A SECOND FAB HERE
IN PHOENIX TO BUILD CHIPS THREE
NANO CHIPS, THE THREE NANO
CHIP -- CHIPS THAT ARE THREE
NANO.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING.
>> Jesse: YOU KNOW WHAT HE IS
SAYING.
IS HE TRYING TO SAY THIS IS A
GUT PUNCH TO CHINA.
ANY TIME WE BRING JOBS TO
AMERICA AND GAIN CONTROL OF THE
CHIP SUPPLY CHAIN IT'S A WIN.
WE ARE DEALING WITH DEMOCRATS
HERE.
THIS $40 BILLION FACTORY IS
GOING TO TAKE YEARS TO FINISH
AND EXECUTIVES ARE GOING TO SKIM
OFF PROBABLY HALF THE BUDGET.
THE LAST THING BIDEN FUNDED IN
PHOENIX WAS AN ANTI RACIST BIRD
WATCHING BRIDGE TO NOWHERE AND
THAT'S GOING TO TAKE AT LEAST
FIVE YEARS TO BUILD AND COST
$25 MILLION.
A SEMICONDUCTOR FACTORY SEEMS A
LITTLE MORE COMPLICATED.
AND AS WITH MOST OF THESE
GOVERNMENT PROJECTS, DEMOCRAT
DONORS ARE PROBABLY GOING TO GET
THE CONTRACTS.
ALL OF THE SUDDEN THE 40 BILLION
TURNS INTO 85 BILLION.
AND WE ARE KEEPING AN EYE ON THE
PELOSI FAMILY PELOSIS LOVE
COMPUTER CHIPS.
THEY HAD BILLIONS, MILLIONS
INVESTED IN NVIDIA.
ALL SET AND RED CAN TO GO FOR
THE CHIPS ACT READY TO PASS.
ALL PERFECTLY TIMED TRADE.
"PRIMETIME" IN THE UNUSUAL
CALLED THEY WILL THEM OUT FORCED
TO SALE FOR THE FIRST ANYTIME A
LONG TIME PAULIE P. TOOK A LOSS.
AND DON'T FORGET WHEN NANCY
SNUCK HER IS ON THE FRESH PRINCE
OF SAN FRANCISCO PAULIE P. JR.
ON TO THE LITTLE PLANE TO ASIA.
REMEMBER?
SHE TOOK HIM TO CHECK OUT SOME
OF THE SEMIQUICK TORE FACTORIES
IN ASIA DESPITE HIM BEING ABOUT
AS QUALIFIED AS HUNTER.
SHE TRIED TO HIDE HIM IN THE
SHADOWS BUT "PRIMETIME" SPOTTED
HIM LURKING BEHIND SOME HEAVY
HITTING MALAYSIANS.
NANCY DIDN'T WANT US TO KNOW
ABOUT HIM OWE IS THE ON THE
PAYROLL OF TWO LITHIUM MINING
COMPANIES.
ASIA HAPPENS TO BE A LITHIUM
GOLD MINE.
HOW ARE THEY GOING TO USE THIS
FACTORY IN ARIZONA TO TACK ON
FEW MORE ZEROS?
WE WILL WATCH THEM CLOSELY.
GOOD TO BRING MANUFACTURING BACK
TO AMERICA.
BUT BIDEN'S TRIP TO ARIZONA
TODAY PURE POLITICS.
THIS IS A RIBBON CUTTING
CEREMONY ON A PLANT THAT HASN'T
BEEN BUILT HE IS JUST DRIVING
HEADLINES IN A BATTLE GROUND
STATE AND PATTING HIMSELF ON THE
BACK FOR THE CHIPS BILL NO.
SURPRISE THERE IT'S PART OF THE
GAME.
BOTH SIDES DO IT.
AFTER HE BURNED ALL THAT JET
FUEL TO FLY ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
WHY NOT STOP BY THE BORDER?
>> MR. PRESIDENT, WHY GO TO A
BORDER STATE AND NOT VISIT THE
BORDER?
>> THERE ARE MORE IMPORTANT
THINGS GOING ON.
THEY ARE GOING TO INVEST
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN A NEW
ENTERPRISE.
>> Jesse: MORE IMPORTANT THINGS.
A F.O.P. AT A CONSTRUCTION SITE
IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN MEETING
WITH BORDER AGENTS?
MORE IMPORTANT THAN SHOWING THE
CARTELS WHO IS BOSS?
MORE IMPORTANT THAN SEEING THE
HOLES IN THE SOUTHERN BORDER
FIRSTHAND?
HE COULD HAVE SENT KAMALA TO THE
FACTORY.
OR HE COULD HAVE JUST HOPPED ON
HIS HELICOPTER.
PHOENIX IS ONLY 100 MILES FROM
THE BORDER.
HE COULD BE THERE IN LESS THAN
AN HOUR.
THAT'S ABOUT THE SAME DISTANCE
HE TRAVELS FROM D.C. TO HIS
DELAWARE BEACH HOUSE.
YOU KNOW, THE HOUSE HE BUILT A
WALL AROUND?
HE IS HAPPY TO TAKE THAT TRIP
TWO OR THREE TIMES A WEEK.
BIDEN HAS LEFT ARIZONA 2:00 P.M.
LOCAL TIME.
HE COULD HAVE HUNG OUT FOR AN
EXTRA HOUR OR TWO.
BIDEN USES THE COMPLAINT ALL THE
TIME HE DOESN'T HAVE ENOUGH TIME
TO VISIT THE BORDER, REMEMBER?
>> DO YOU HAVE PLANS TO VISIT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> I HAVE BEEN THERE BEFORE AND
I HAVEN'T -- I MEAN, I KNOW IT
WELL.
I GUESS I SHOULD GO DOWN BUT
THE -- BUT, THE WHOLE POINT OF
IT IS, I HAVEN'T HAD A WHOLE
HELL OF A LOT OF TIME TO GET
DOWN.
>> Jesse: TODAY HE HAS GOT TIME.
BUT IT IS JUST NOT THAT
IMPORTANT ENOUGH.
HE KNOWS THAT'S NOT TRUE.
WHEN YOU HAVE DONE SOMETHING
WRONG IT'S HARD TO FACE IT.
JUST LIKE A KID WHO WON'T LOOK
YOU IN THE EYE AFTER GETTING
CAUGHT IN A LIE.
INSTEAD OF FESSING UP THE WHITE
HOUSE DIGS DEEPER.
>> DO YOU KNOW IF THE PRESIDENT
HAS NEVER BEEN DOWN TO THE
BORDER.
THE POSSIBLE NEXT SPEAKER SAID
THAT HE'S HIM TO GO WITH HIM.
SO IS HE GOING TO?
>> SO, LOOK, HE HAS BEEN THERE.
HE HAS BEEN TO THE BORDER.
AND SINCE HE TOOK OFFERS.
>> WHEN DID HE GO TO THE BORDER?
>> SINCE HE TOOK OFFICE, THE
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS BEEN TAKING
ACTION TO FIX OUR IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM.
AND TO SECURE OUR BORDER.
>> Jesse: 40 YEARS IN WASHINGTON
NEVER BEEN TO THE BORDER.
5 MILLION ILLEGALS THAT WE KNOW
OF CROSSED THE BORDER SINCE
BIDEN TOOK OVER.
THAT'S FIXING OUR IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM.
FENTANYL SEIZURE IS UP ALMOST
500 PERCENT.
ENOUGH TO KILL THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY TEN TIMES OVER.
THAT'S SECURING THE BORDER?
THAT'S WHAT THEY CAUGHT BY THE
WAY.
LOOK HOW EASY IT IS TO GET IN
OUR COUNTRY.
>> MAN, MAN, LOOK AT THIS.
YOU GOT A BROTHER TRIPPING.
BRO.
LOOK AT THAT.
[BLEEP]
>> DUDE, LOOK AT THAT, BRO.
THIS IS OUR GOVERNMENT [BLEEP]
MONEY, BRO.
YES, SIR.
ANOTHER ONE.
WOO!
>> Jesse: THOSE WEREN'T BORDER
AGENTS RECORDING THAT TAPE.
AS FAR AS WE KNOW, THEY NEVER
GOT CAUGHT.
WHAT WAS IN THE BACKPACK?
WHO KNOWS?
THERE IS PLENTY MORE VIDEOS LIKE
THAT ONE.
MIGRANTS DASHING THROUGH TRAFFIC
AFTER JUMPING INTO THE COUNTRY.
OUR COUNTRY IS OPEN TO ANYBODY
WHO WANTS IN.
CHINESE DRUG SMUGGLERS, CARTEL
HIT MEN, TERRORISTS.
ALL THEY HAVE TO DO IS GET TO
MEXICO AND WALK NORTH.
DOOR'S WIDE OPEN.
COME ON IN.
NOT IMPORTANT TO THE PRESIDENT.
TODAY'S BORDER BOYCOTT SIGNALS
THAT FOR THE REST OF THE BID